demi lovato strips down to promote her  new song  I'm excited here's the cover art for  dummies next single body say the newly  single star poses topless her back  toward the camera her bra draped across  the bed and here's some more shots from  the shoot Demi shared on Instagram  rolling around on that bad at showing  off her Fit Body and tattoos the single  isn't out quite yet but Demi did debut  it in Atlanta Wednesday night it was the  first stop on her new tour with Nick at  Jonas  we gotta say the new song has a bit of a  new sound for dummy last month at the 23  year old told ET she was experimenting  are you tweeting that you actually just  wrote a new song within an hour and  recorded it what does it sound like can  you tease it at all um I would love to  but I kind of want to keep people  guessing yeah it's like a feed ballot  I've written so much that honestly I  just don't remember which one you're  talking about new album are you working  on the follow-up